how are you doing today sir
i'm well how are you sir i can't
complain
uh i want to start by saying uh congrats
on the emmy
thank you um did you know was this even
on your radar or something that like
could happen with the emmys were you
even
not at all i was totally caught off
guard by it i was really surprised
after seeing your work in this i just
want to say it's um it's deserved
um one of the things about this is that
it's unfortunately about this project um
is that it's unfortunately
just as relevant like there's no
you'd think at some point we would you
know be able to you know what i'm
basically trying to say you know exactly
what you mean and i feel exactly the
same way
it is bittersweet that um you know this
story is so relevant
yeah um one of the things about this is
that it does
shine a light on the the problems with
our justice system
for uh it's unfortunate that i would
like to think that if
if rajon was white would this same exact
thing have happened
you know um it's just very powerful
stuff
yeah it has power it has the power of
the moment it has the power of the
history
our history collectively um
and hopefully it has enough power to
help us
you know course correct for the future
quimby does a great job when you're
watching this
leaving you with these cliffhangers that
makes you have you did you watch it
yourself where you're pushing play after
each episode
oh absolutely i was completely caught up
i mean even in even in reading it
i was caught up in it the way in which
it was broken down
into the 15 episodes it's absolutely
compelling and that was one of the
exciting things about
the idea behind quibby and their
presentation of dramatic
material is that they leave you with a
cliffhanger each and every episode
oh i kept pushing play there was no
break yeah you know um
i am curious though you've done so many
roles are you
able to when you're playing a character
like this are you able to leave
the character on set at the end of the
day or during a shoot does that sort of
character stay with you
at least a little bit until you've
wrapped and maybe even post
wrap i have learned how to leave
things on the set it wasn't always that
way for me
it took me about 20 years to figure that
out but i i've got it down now the
separation
if you don't mind me asking what was a
character or a role that you played that
really stuck with you
after you wrapped that took you a little
while to shake
uh the character i played in apocalypse
now took me about three years to shake
him
okay but that was also
i believe if i'm not mistaken that was
like a year-long shoot or something two
years
yeah so i i can't imagine being in that
headspace for so long
yeah it took me about three years to
shake him now you know i was very young
i was 14 when i started
i was going to make a joke and you were
30 when you finished
damn near right i am curious though um
what what are you getting ready to do
anything in the upcoming future
uh any roles or how has covid sort of
impacted what you were gonna do
well we were uh rehearsing i was in
rehearsal with um
sam rockwell and darren chris
and neil pepe for american buffalo on
the stage in new york city
uh back in march and so
once uh once it became clear that
you know quarantine was necessary and
all of that
we we just resorted to rehearsing on
zoom and facetime
so hopefully you know as things
change because things always change
maybe we'll get the opportunity to do
that live or
maybe not maybe we'll you know do it in
a different kind of format who knows
on that note congrats again on getting
nominated and
um uh wish you nothing but the best
thank you you stay safe